it continued on The View because the
other part
when I mentioned how sometimes if the
color of the shooter or the ideology of
the shooter fits and the victims if that
fits the narrative and we know what that
narrative is they love it if it's a
white Christian shooting minorities then
this is the greatest thing ever for the
media if it doesn't work out that way
they don't know exactly what to do with
it in this case it was a trans shooter
going into a Christian school now you
would believe
by by any notion if someone walks into a
temple and shoots a bunch of Jewish
people it is obviously somehow connected
to their religion much like this is
obviously connected to their religion of
Christianity but that does not compute
for these people it does not work in
their very deranged worldview so here is
Whoopi having no knowledge no knowledge
of what she is saying saying that no
this was not about these people being
Christians
is a real conversation that everybody's
willing to get on board with children
are going to keep getting shot people in
churches are going to keep getting shot
I heard one guy said well you know this
is this is against the Christians no
it's not against a Christian because you
would have mentioned it when they went
into the black church and you would have
said this is an issue we should be
thinking about what you did so let's not
do that let's not make it let's not make
it about transgender people let's not
make it about anything but what it is we
have a problem with this gun and its
accessibility in this country
she's just wrong
she's just fundamentally wrong you know
I have guns in this house
I would never take those guns and go
into a church or a mosque or a school
and shoot someone I have those guns so I
can protect my family and my property I
know that several of the other people in
this room have guns and that's the same
reason they have it it's about mental
illness and ideology that's what this is
about but she dismisses all of that and
and it's really bizarre that she she
really doesn't want you to think it has
anything to do with the victims being
Christian but it obviously does this
person was not happy with the way they
perceive Christian people to treat trans
people okay you know there's this
Manifesto supposedly I think it's a 27
page Manifesto that they're trying to
figure out whether they should release
right now and I'm actually 50 50 on
whether they should release it I was
discussing it off camera with Thomas
Massey because on one hand i'm for
transparency obviously right and so on
one hand you'd want to get it out so
you'd have a little more insight into
actually why did this person do this the
problem though is that once you release
it and then it goes viral and people are
clipping it and reading it and it's read
everywhere and the people everyone knows
this person's name and all that you're
actually incentivizing the copycatters
to go boy if I do something
unimaginably evil like evil that is that
is so anti-human
that you really can't think about it
killing children uh the media will read
my scribe they will read my Rants and I
will become famous after life so there
is a push and a pull on that that I
think you can make good arguments on on
both sides but she is completely
dismissive of the fact that the victims
were Christians she only wants to make
this about guns and she somehow connects
that to when when there's been shootings
in black churches except Whoopi when
when there have been shootings in black
churches churches it's because they're
going after black people and they're
going after Christians who happen to be
black in those churches you're the one
disconnecting reality from all of this
thank you
[Music]
foreign